i got that dawg lightning in a bottle
blip that's crazy son all it does is
this
i got it don't leave out man
this is one ten dollars on this scratch
off honey
quit pulling my dick
what come up in here lying to me
i ain't buying it you pulling my dick
first of all i ain't lying to you and
second of all
that's not the phrase come up in here
piss on my dick tell me it's raining
piss on my leg and tell me it's raining
all right see now you wanna piss
and pull on my dick come on
do you understand that you got all your
wrongs uh no actually
you got it wrong yeah
i yeah see you ain't even got a dick to
stand on it
okay okay let me ask you a question
what do you call those old plastic
building blocks what you mean dickos
name a famous comic strip detective leg
tracy
what's with the questions man
do you know the name of a giant cartoon
rooster
foghorn dickhorn okay you done you done
give it
all right yo you just got you got to
leave now huh
just cause i got a dick up on you
i'm elected to marijuana
this weed is mad tight y'all yeah man
i'm
super hot dog
hey y'all let me ask you a question on
the wheel
yeah yeah dog yeah go ahead man
hey man where'd my dookie go
oh what
my dookie where do we go
it go down in the toilet you know that
no man
i ain't stupid where do we go after that
come on man quit playing i don't know it
goes to the sewer you know
everybody go down there yeah everybody's
dookie goes down to the sewer
where my dookie go after that that
washes out to the ocean
i guess hold up hold up
dolphins swim with my dookie i don't
know man
i mean i don't i really don't know we're
in the ocean yep
what happens to the dookie i'm just
taking a stab like a wild guess
all right that the dookie like probably
go up in the air and like evaporates and
then turns into the cloud or something
a dookie cloud oh this
everybody's to keep mix-up
goes up into the cloud and then it rains
down
that's gangsta i just can we stop
talking about doogie right now
i just thought of something yes what is
it what is it levi the pieces of my
dookie
yep falls on the ground that's true yeah
it becomes a plan
okay okay that's good now we're done
with the dookie talk right dookie plan
nope that reaches towards the sky
ah they said
yeah levi if my dookie can make it out
of the hood
maybe we can too
huh
maybe maybe levi
oh good you hungry
i could eat yeah man um what you want uh
pizza chinese kill that noise man
i got a ratatouille
oh that's a wrap dude all right
that's a ratatouille yo
they rather to it go make my man a
sandwich
yes show him what you got
[Music]
what the sign you let a rat up in your
house
what does mean
i don't know what to say man i got a
ratatouille man he a chef just like in
all that movies man
no no hey there's only there's only one
movie
levi all right and he's not a
ratatouille he's a rat
and his name is remy potato potato
potato
i gots myself some ratatouille that's
all i know
order up damn come on levi
[Music]
voila levi look at this thing man
you see it got bite marks all over it
any good chef has to taste his creation
that's rat on the sandwich
he didn't make a sandwich though oh hell
no i'm out
my dude you need help
oh well ratatouille another negative
review
maybe you wanted charlotte's web
oh no please don't say anything please
just keep it to yourself whatever
oh thought you had an idea i do
we need to make an app like for a
smartphone
an app that all the people could
download and then we make millions
this is hard to come up with man it's
like catching lightning in a bottle
i already got that you got what
lightning in the bottle really what's
the idea no no idea
i got actual lightning in a bottle
no levi that's just a phrase
i got that dawg lightning in a bottle
blip that's crazy son where'd you get
that some old chinese man sold it to me
years ago
i mean that's some supernatural man
man all it does is this
i got it but seriously man
would it be like an app that reminds you
when your favorite television shows are
on
no we got to address this crazy ass
bottle that you got
what bottle what bottle
the bottle with the lightning in it
you still on that yes
how does it work cedric i don't know
it's the classic
lightning in the bottle guys classic you
just open it
okay you know what you shouldn't have
this this
belongs to the military or something but
that app though
no we don't need the app you've got the
goose that laid the golden egg
how do you know about hunkers
what this [ __ ]
hunkers get in on this app idea
you like it he likes it
yeah he got a goddamn golden head
honkers here is the cat's pajamas
no please don't don't i want to show you
something whatever it is i don't want to
see it it's relevant
i already know what it is it ain't what
you think
well what i think it is is a pair of
cats pajamas
these are for honkers to wear the what
the little neck in there the neck how
you gonna fit his head
through this with the the orange pump
[Music]
i'm gonna have to ask you to leave my
house
why because you disrespected
my roommate okay
okay it's clear that this is a crazy
house so i gotta go
you over here talking about geese the
golden eggs and feline sleepwear
oh man cedric you need to get off your
high horse man
hey i just thought of a name for you
high horse
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
oh there you are cedric
sup dude tis well cedric tiswell
yeah can i ask you a question man um
why the hell are you dressed like this
and what the hell did you do to your
bike
you ain't heard i'm steampunk now
yeah i don't know what that is man
jules vernon
i seriously think that you have cracked
man
all right like like in your mind nah
i ain't cracked up i live in a clock now
ah umbrellas and blimps
you're wearing a top hat with a door on
it
i'm just an ill-ass lemony snicket up in
this [ __ ]
but you what's with you what's with me
i'll tell you what i'm i'm an ill-ass
normal mother
who've been waiting for his friend for
hour and ten minutes underneath a
goddamn bridge
with two homeless perchance good sir
could you point me in the direction
of the nearest apothecary
if you're talking about the drugstore
it's right there on the corner
what time does it close it closes at 10
o'clock man
you've been there a million times i'll
check just to be sure
make sure it's still open i'm telling
you levi if you put that piece of pipe
up to your eye and use it as a telescope
i cannot be your friend anymore
this yup it's still open
all right i have to go then so you try
it
no no i'm not gonna try it because it's
a piece of pipe and it doesn't have any
lenses in it
therefore it's not a telescope yes but
how could you be sure
science i'm gonna look through this
piece of pipe and if it doesn't work
like a telescope then we finally done
man like not homies anymore we're done
[Music]
oh cedric why
would you think in a million
years that that would actually work
cedric is just dead you look so
ridiculous right now
say goodbye ratatouille what
what the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
[Music]
me